tone for that manager of meanwhile he's
been playing a lot as well lately and
he's been in decent form so okay he gets
things started it's d4 it's uh queen's
pawn opening rapport who knows what
he'll play he's a maverick uh when it
comes to choosing openings as well he
often chooses some very weird wacky
stuff just to get the opponent thinking
from an early stage
and uh okay will we see the nimzo indian
will we see
king's indian defense
rapport okay he pushes this pawn maybe a
king's indian uh maybe we'll see your
beloved opening the grunfeld uh who
knows i mean the one thing that i must
say about rapport is that whatever he
surprises us is by playing mainstream
open yes
we're so used to seeing the quirky stuff
from him and uh okay he is not going to
go for david's favorite just yet so i
have to
reel back my words in a little bit and
now okay now we
have mama jarov also playing one of his
favorite kind of openings where he
pushes his g pawn one square in order to
develop the light square to the long
long the longest diagonal on the board
yeah that white bishop when it sits on
g2 will be fantastic and
um i think this is just intended to
frustrate rapport rapport wanted white
to occupy the center with pawns he
wanted white to gain as much space as
possible so that he would have targets
to counter-attack later on meanwhile
this black knight moves very ambitious
maybe not the most common either
black now will try and counter the white
center with a pawn of his own on the
next turn so depending on what white
does black will strike back yeah and
here comes the quirky move you know it
has been played before but this porn
move is actually a little bit rare it's
actually been played by wesley so to
defeat jordan van forest and the chess
ball masters
so that was a very long game
um it was interesting actually to have
access to the database here because uh
my major had actually played this
particular line until this porn move
and it was in a game that he had lost
so i always wonder how much preparation
how much knowledge the opponent has
and
after
let me just uh get these moves up
okay so white meanwhile occupying the
center with as many pawns as possible
this is uh
hyper amber uh ambitious
trying to take all the central squares
this has however left a target as we
mentioned
for richer report at least now he knows
what he has to attack and that is the
white pawn center so one of the black
pawns will push forward black
temporarily as well ahead into
peace development if you see the white
pieces white's king's still in the
center white's king side night still sat
at home
that means you have to
do something quickly you have to act and
report does that very strange he just
pushed this pawn one square
he's pushed it again listen on the next
move he forgot that pawns can move
forward two squares on their first go uh
either that or he was trying to be
something uh trying to do something very
very clever on this last turn so he's
lost the tempo willingly
by moving this pawn twice but uh now at
least the black knight when things block
up in the center the black knight can
occupy this key square in the center
yeah
i was a bit surprised by this uh double
pawn move he made with uh the e porn
i i was expecting something a little bit
more safer you know that maybe he would
curl up into
into a ball just for the time being and
just wait it out we need an action
replay ivanka because um if this black
pawn had pushed forward two squares
immediately if it had marched forward to
e5 then suddenly after the white pawn
steps forward black's knight could jump
in as it has done in the game but it
would just get kicked away and the
knight has to retreat run away that's
not ideal that's not great but by
pushing the pawn forward one square i'm
sorry in this position by pushing the
pawn forward to e6 waiting for white to
commit and then pushing it forward a
second square yes he's lost to move as
black so white has gained this pawn push
for free but because the white pawn is
now on e4
in this position after the knight jumps
in now this knight is on an outpost this
white pawn because it's committed itself
cannot kick away the black knight so
it's
it's very sophisticated
it's a bit too advanced for me i would
never dream of pushing a pawn two
squares forward kind of in mini steps uh
i would want to save time but rapport is
not biased he doesn't care there this
night now it's actually quite hard to
get rid of if you attack it with your
own knight then black will probably just
cement this pawn uh push this pawn
forward to cement the knight now
defending it this way this way and white
can actually capture on passantier uh
capturing the black pawn as if it just
moved to one square but now after a
recapture black again defends this night
with his board defends his knight
with his queen as well so
this is hard to get rid of
and well my majority is actually going
to try do you think we're going to see
something super wild like opposite side
castling be very mamadorf
i was thinking that but now actually
that he's put his knight on this
particular square i'm kind of going off
the idea of putting the king on opposite
ends
uh so you were thinking for example
maybe bring the bishop forward yeah at
some point lifting the queen up one
square so for example if black just
waits i mean the queen up castling the
king of this flank yeah and then
push forward with the pawns strange have
the time of your life
maybe do or die by your own sword if
they were playing for the fans rather
than playing for points they would
definitely do this
but uh okay in the current position
it's a pity we didn't see that instead
white tonight was attacking the black
knight and rapport did as expected
pushes pawn forward
solidifying in the center
um okay well we have to do some maths
here
there might be some capture of the pawn
in the center yeah white tonight can
take a pawn and uh black's night now i
guess will jump out the way this knight
we know is not protected white's king is
well in the center so there might be
some ideas of a rook shifting across
later to attack the white king but uh
knight takes pawn i guess i'm not sure
which pawn to capture in the center
suddenly
two nights up for grabs black's knight
on priests as we would say attacked and
this knight also attacked
and as ivanka mentioned you can do some
maths uh it's like a kind of who can
give up their piece for the most uh
most reward most compensation here white
can give up this night for a pawn for
example uh hoping that the night is
captured so that you can gain the black
knight next move um at a high price but
the problem is black's knight will take
this night and suddenly the white queen
is attacked and it's too complicated in
general to calculate but the players
they are trying to work this out that's
why majora's taking some time in general
the rule is this kind of stuff won't
work for white if your king is in the
center of the board this king is too
open so um we do see the first night
capture but after the black knight takes
i don't think we'll see any more fun and
games from mamadoura no definitely not i
have a question for you because when i i
mentioned that it's about maths when we
start off playing chess often it's very
difficult to visualize so far and ahead
and often you see lots of people use
their fingers yeah like they are they're
there is this allowed
oh that's a good question
are you allowed to stop going don't say
things out loud
ah
i don't know we need some arbiters yeah
tweet us the solution are you allowed to
kind of gesticulate and try to
work out your calculations because i can
tell you when i'm solving puzzles
i'm not above doing that myself
i mean for example anyone who's watched
the streams of hikaru nakamura would say
would know that he would do this on a
chessboard he would say
there there
there
there
there
there
and then it would the arrows would just
go on and on and on
most people have no idea what he's
talking about but he's actually
formulating a path for his brain to
think so all of these arrows i've just
showed it would be a capture followed by
a recaptcha followed by another capture
followed by another capture another
capture and at the end black wins with a
check um so he would be saying they're
there there there there but as it's
basically a way of what ivanka is saying
it's kind of pointing just to keep
i think anyone could see these ideas
given enough time but it's just about
keeping in the right order and uh making
sure you haven't messed up along the way
so it's interesting what your anchor
says i don't i haven't seen anyone do
that out loud for a long long time since
i was a kid but uh if we go back to the
game meanwhile we did actually reach
this position
knight takes pawn does walk into a queen
check so instead we saw white castle his
king to safety and now attack this black
queen
so no more long long variations that are
confusing with loads of arrows it's just
a simple one move threat and the black
queen really needs to get out the way
you don't want to block this bishop
attack with your pawn because when the
bishop moves then suddenly there's a
threat against your rook but also the
black bishop in the center of the board
is trapped it has no squares
once the black rook goes to safety
suddenly this bishop
is a goner it's just leaving the board
on the next turn so
um instead black's queen moved away i
don't really like this square it looks a
bit odd
i must say i just don't understand why
the queen didn't for example go to this
square at least attacking a pawn yeah
but uh yeah now maybe mamajorov can use
this square as a launching pad for an
attack at some point
throw in a check you could definitely
imagine a situation where white starts
pushing pawns towards the black king
yeah i'm just thinking that uh you could
you could uh push to push your pawns
forward
and uh once the bishop steps back
i mean
it's very tempting to also give a check
to the king
and forcing the king yeah
one thing black definitely doesn't want
to do is trade off his pride and joy the
dark squad bishop because suddenly look
at the dark squares around the black
king if the white queen ever lands here
it's simply checkmate
so white's queen will do a little dance
try to creep into the dark squares this
bishop too strong um
could it be a mouse slip by mom jarv
that he dropped his queen one square too
early
by a report yeah
yeah by reports yeah it doesn't make any
sense why this square
it just looks so passive i mean it's
still
it's a safe square but what's it doing
here and i like that variation ivanka
showed pushing pawns forward kind of
gaining momentum threatening the bishop
next move threatening the king and then
maybe pushing again forward trying to
sneak in the queen this way towards the
black king i think this would be
fantastically strong um but okay instead
very solid move there from majora for
just moving his rook across still ideas
of jumping in with a night nasty check
if that happens actually i took a peek
at the computer evaluation and for that
reason and only that reason why it had
an amazing position wow
and uh
so a small kind of window of opportunity
that i missed by manager and uh now
richard is fine he just has to
consolidate his king position and this
is why
he pushes forward with his pawn to
attack the knight and also take control
of that important
f6 square
yeah so slightly counter-intuitive this
last move by rapport it looks like he's
weakening the black king by stepping
forward with this pawn but it's more
important to kick away the white knight
from any active squares
so the white knight now falls to retreat
simply and at least then rapport has two
or three moves with which to consolidate
if black can move his light squad bishop
get the black rook out of the corner
centralize it then black's pieces are
all actually looking great
the black queen's still not ideal but uh
other than that yeah it's uh back in the
balance again it is certainly back on
the balance i actually quite like
rapport's position you know his pieces
suddenly the queen
that we kind of criticized moving to the
seventh row can actually divert itself
to stepping forward to sorry to move and
forward or move forward to in front of
its king and it has a lot of dexterity
and uh
black has a lot of the pawn breaks so
definitely a very very complicated
position
and uh i'm just curious i mean both
these players are actually playing from
germany right because they've both been
playing in the bundesliga yeah that's
true yeah
and uh i i'm dying to see how they get
on because they have to play a
complicated game after having played a
very long classical game so it's always
going to be very intriguing whether
their stamina holds up
and uh talking about locations and where
the players are playing from we also
love it when you guys tell us and show
us where you guys are watching the show
and all the action from and to kick us
off jmr18
has sent us a selfie and says he's
watching us from the local greek
restaurant oh so good food
and of course entertainment and good
chefs as well maybe on a summer holiday
in greece oh
i even better yeah even better okay so
if you want to make us jealous send us
your tweets using the hashtag
chesschamps yeah where are you following
the ftx summer of chess we have
partnered up with ftx both for this
tournament the road to miami and the
next tournament the big major in miami
the ftx crypto cup so maybe you are
following us from outside or at some
holiday location share your selfies we
want to see where you're watching from
we do have a move we do have a move
white tonight simply stepping back to a
safe square and
yeah i mean poor rapport he he probably
wants a holiday after the candidates
after this tournament and uh i mean
before that he was playing in other
events before the candidates
yeah it's been a long few months for him
major of two actually he's been playing
a lot some online chess i'm over the
board chess
look at mom and darrow just deep in
thought and you did mention the
candidates richard report he ended in
last place out of the eight players
competing in the candidates what went
wrong for him and of course comment on
the move if it's something interesting
happening black just connecting the
rooks developing a piece very sensible
yeah for rapport it was a tournament of
two halves uh the first half he drew i
think it was his first
five games
and uh then he met janna pogneshi at a
really critical moment and upon if she's
already won a couple of games at this
point
and report he walked into some opening
preparation
which led to a forced draw so the game
should have been a draw rapport was
surprised he thought for over one hour
against napolishi and then he decided
not to take the draw but by refusing the
draw he immediately walked into a losing
position
and he lost the game in a way he gifted
napolishi
kind of a shot at the title he which he
later took and
i think he just never recovered from
that report he actually won a game in
the next round but then second half the
event he just fell apart i think he had
what was it three losses uh in the
second half as well so
it's difficult again just like duda it's
his first time in the candidates
tournament
are we about to see a cool move we do
see a cool sacrifice for majora
meanwhile so we have to jump back to the
game but yeah learning experience for a
report and he'll be back
meanwhile there has been some action if
we just uh repeat the last couple of
moves a bit of an action replay white's
bishop jumped in attacking this black
rook and after the rook moved we saw a
sacrifice for mama jaroff the first
sacrifice of the game we knew it was
going to happen at some point he gave up
his rook for this very strong black
bishop and after the rook was
captured his pawn forward and
wow okay a mistake then from uh
mahamajarov but let's catch up the queen
was attacked the queen did move and this
was the mistake maybe was it a mistake
though it looks so strong it looks so
natural the white knight jumping in
hitting the black queen and the black
queen taking a pawn but look at what's
about to happen the black queen is about
to move because she's hit by the white
rook and when she does move out the way
white's rook might just come up and take
this pawn there are also some ideas of
knight checks in the air this knight
check hitting the king hitting the
bishop will force black to give back the
material
uh the rook will now have to
give itself up for this night and
suddenly
i love white's position i've got to say
at least in practical terms i just don't
see any defenders around this black king
i'm looking at this white bishop sitting
there nice and pretty but it's about to
do some nasty checking of the black king
and i'm also looking at the white queen
later it takes a while but later you
could try and sneak her in
to deliver checkmate as well
this looks really scary rapport however
is two pawns up if we reach this
position he still has two extra pawns
for black it's just about whether those
can survive
uh i mean to be honest the more i look
at it the more i love white's position
also this very strong past pawn in the
center
it just looks terrible
it looks absolutely awful you know
there's no solace to be found anywhere
you know the past pawn you mentioned
that's going to be great oh and it's
going to it's going to happen david yeah
so in the current position this is a
check and this knight cannot be
tolerated if you move your king then you
simply lose your bishop and that is not
good so you have to get rid of this
knight uh why is report even thinking
i'm not so sure but uh yeah i see ivanka
says it's looking terrible this bishop
attacking a pawn okay this isn't the
current position this pawn attacked this
pawn attacked and black's king
almost terminally weak so uh it's going
to be very difficult here i mean even an
endgame if you manage to trade off the
queens is not going to help black
because white has this amazing possible
and it's not the quantity of pawns you
have it's the quality and that pawn it's
a monster and
if you don't trade off queens then you
always have to worry you know rook is
going to come to the seventh rank if
it's not a rook it's a queen that's also
going to snake her way into the dark
squares ah no and also it's not just
that there's also a light square bishop
that's going to come and deliver some
horrible some checks and there's a pawn
up for that would mean it's just a long
list of what is wrong with black's
position
you guys are basically definitely
disagreeing with the bar right now and i
i'm trying to find a reason to be honest
yeah unless it's something really
concrete that we haven't seen i'm
looking at black's bishop for example
attacking the white queen here i don't
think this really helps um maybe the
idea is that you can trade off this
light square bishop but i was just
wondering why can't white trade off
these bishops now and march this white
pawn forward it just looks very very
strong this pawn is about to make a new
queen and cost black a rook
yeah let's go back to the players
because it's a mystery to me what are
the players thinking from a human point
of view this looks great for white a
computer point of view though not clear
at all ah okay
and majority looks happy though
well my german geoff is an element right
this is the position that he thrives in
um he's two pawns down but i mean he's
sacrificed a lot more for a lot less
than this so
yeah it's
it's really mine i mean it's really
bemusing it's
just struggling to understand what
can the computer see that we don't see
here
just looks fantastic for white should we
take up the
stock fish to see what can i see we'll
move the fish wants to
suggest for richard report okay so
actually maybe there's only one move to
maintain the balance ah everything else
does give white an advantage as we are
predicting here and this nut this night
check the black knight jumping into the
e2 square that is not 100 obvious it's
on the radar of course because all top
players look for checks and then
captures and then threats in that order
but uh it needs to be followed up and i
don't see him yeah i don't see either
let's jump in because it the night check
on its own would not be logical it has
to have a follow-up so the night check
a check defended by the black queen
the white king is just going to move and
what next
is the idea for the black knight to jump
back attacking the queen attacking the
rook
i mean the knight is just going to get
uh and the queen are just going to get
caught off the side for instance you
mean for starters you can move the queen
one square yeah on the dark squares
hitting the knight and the knight
captures the rook whoops
this is gonna mate ends the game yeah i
i just don't see how the king escapes
this is going to be checkmate
is there a glitch with stockfish are we
missing something really obvious here i
mean is there something
funny thing with instead of taking the
rook like
so with this night check this is what
the computer says first the white king
will just move out the way to any safe
square what is next
because this is just a killer threat now
the white queen is trying to get in with
a check
i don't think rapport is going to find
this move even if there is a solution
even if the computers find something
it's just not human to allow uh the
white queen into your position like this
and i mean if you look at where the
knight is right now at least the knight
blocks the white queen from entering uh
on the d-file so
i don't think he'll find that move the
other moves we should mention stockfish
also suggests bishop to c6
this square this is very logical
challenging the white bishop we showed
that this is very uh this is maybe a
decent try but it would allow for
example a trade and white's pawn to run
through black's bishop was previously
blockading this pawn and the bishop is
gone now so this pawn might be a decider
so that from a human point of view is
scary and the other move that the
computer suggests i can tell you for a
fact this will not happen black's rook
just sliding across one square
rook b8 that's very passive so the third
choice for stopfish that's not report
instinct i've never seen him go passive
in his life um he wants to fight fire
with fire he doesn't want to
just say okay i'm just gonna take a
timeout
i guess the idea is that you stop the
white rook from entering the position on
this square but
it's just so slow and it does
nothing to stop the white bishop jumping
in so
ah very from a human point of view very
very difficult at least for rapport i'm
very i really hope now he will make that
night jump so that we can get an answer
from stockfish what is the follow-up
from the strange move
and all the while mama jarrah just looks
a bit casual right
one eye on the computer one eye on some
drink i want to say i think a mixture of
snacks and drinks uh that major is
enjoying and why not you need some fuel
for the rapid chess and it's been a long
day for him uh playing in the bundesliga
yeah
i'm so impressed by that incredible
they're all marathon runners basically
these guys yeah non-stop chess
five minutes now on this move for
richard report
yeah it's it's a critical position you
know it's uh win or lose time you know
everything will hinge on whether he can
find a resource we can't see it
uh stockfish has uh broken us or we've
broken stockfish we don't know
but yeah um but we don't get what the
stockfish is trying to
say is black's defense and report he's
just kind of stretching in a way he's
trying to psych himself up because he
knows it's a very difficult position
i mean even if you can handle the first
wave of the attack the first two or
three threats there will be a second
wave there will be more threats to come
a bit later on so even if the computer
says black is fine for the next three or
four moves it's beyond that he will
still have to defend and black's king
just zero defenders around it
i just from a practical point of view
can't see any hope really here maybe i'm
just too negative i i think i've just
seen too many amazing attacks by majira
off and uh i've been on the wrong side
of some of those attacks occasionally
so uh yeah manager of i think a big
favorite right now just from the body
language the clock the type of position
on the board
yeah
oh this is so tense yeah it's a key
moment if he doesn't find any of those
three top moves because none of them
were obvious maybe the second one the
black bishop moving that is the most
obvious out of all of them but it has a
clear downside to it okay he moves his
bishop i mentioned that this is on the
radar attacking the white queen but the
white oh
look at that is that a blunder yeah
blunder i think we're going to see a
nice checkmating attack white's light
squared bishop now is going to come to
the center of the board giving a check
and
i'm trying to work out ivanka can white
just give up the queen i'm working out
um yeah we've got to share it right
because it is possible it's going to be
a brutal mating attack just keep an eye
on the players look at mama jarov though
look at the
laser sharp focus that he's suddenly got
on his face he is super interested in
this position and that's because right
now white can give a check hitting the
black king only one safe square to go to
you have to move and now you can give up
the white queen you can ignore the
threat against her okay the first
check's on the board you can bring your
rook up the board take a pawn and after
the queen drops suddenly you give a
check this is very simple if the king
goes to the center wow he sacrifices
queen he didn't even think and now this
would be checkmate if the king goes to
the center if it goes the other way then
uh this is checkmate as well
look at this the king will be checkmated
in the corner of the board a double
check and we have a result amazing
checkmate there from mamadarov wow after
26 moves it is over between